all cigarettes my spirit back welcome to
the evil within I got an exclusive
chance to play this game for your breath
we start off in Chapter four I have this
old friend with us anyway we have a
bunch of places to explore I think I'm
gonna up God Jesus crime so except for
this game I like some [ __ ] spooky
let's go in this house oh god I can hear
stuff oh god what is that hello I saw
something no okay well we're not going
there then so we're looking for a girl I
know that from an ambulance this creepy
noise oh god they seized a base
everything let's take it easy Empress I
know you can crunch I know this song
dude is this a mystical planet or
something let's take some liquor
you never know okay what did I do that
or next okay I think I woke in someone
where's the door oh hi guys Hey Sekou it
good to see it let's try and sneak up on
there okay
what is going on here what are they
doing Oh God Oh God
look at the pink all right let's try
something this guy all right don't be
such a crybaby
Jesus this music released victory cake
Carol well what does it look like mate
here in my line of sight what are you
doing what there we go
oh poor Peggy I'm sorry I'll come rescue
you give me back Peggy BAM boom huh okay
okay by me funding funding funding
Clemmy that's Plan B all right and
that's how it's done
so you have to let them on fire other
ways they don't properly guy there you
go you look hot today
this is over it is our don't cry for me
Argentina thinking I've come to rescue
you that follow me
you're licking my shoes baby this is
very rare
I guess we're not after the piggy yeah I
guess Pig it wasn't the girl after all
that makes me a little sad oops not my
audio should be better sorry about that
oh god it's going to call every one of
those creatures within earshot with an
ear shot what is going on here there's a
lot of duck [ __ ] in this town alright
we must find my patient Leslie - that's
her name Leslie yes
every guy hello
let's go in here bad ass kick what's up
bring it well goddammit thought at least
someone would respond let's get this
let's always do the bottle check great
fit opiates ten points to me all right
whatever get o matches awesome biggest
set of matches I've ever seen in my life
this lady's cozy can I sleep here oh
that's awesome I can sleep if I wanted
to I love sleeping this game really
speaks to me dog stay close
god damn I didn't know you were such a
wimp doc calm your tits man all right
let's go down in the basement I'm sure
nothing bad is gonna happen down here
except horrible death and suffering
hello
all right let's just take it is
obviously a corridor of death I've seen
many of these be careful now this is a
trap isn't it hello oh it's too quiet
her poon oh I'm full well that bet is
sorry using the harpoon then what is
going on what just happened
oh oh I got scared by the title screen
it happens it happens to the best of us
okay I don't trust this why is it red
hello
that's weird what do you think I'm doing
brah
come on all right all right now god it's
lightning man what is going on here
super cute place I love what they've
done with it I think some racist [ __ ] up
goddamn it oh god oh [ __ ]
all right mate all right just everyone
calm everyone calm I did down looks
completed that was connects blowed yeah
anywhere safe at all
I think that's unlikely we must be going
this way I'm trying but I can't get away
there we go let's see what she was using
it or some kind of witch brew and I'll
take that
all right note to self don't use the
harpoon unless they're far away got it
well at least we got the Leslie girl I'm
very happy now what
now the stairs have gone what must be
collectively losing our minds well that
makes sense
Oh God
ruvik it is you hell are you don't
follow don't follow can't tell me what
that oh yeah come ahktar just Leslie um
alright then [ __ ]
we are indeed [ __ ] well I guess we'll
go to this little door here let's reload
this gun by the way you really don't
have a lot of ammo oh come on what what
are you even talking about
do you even know her hooked up bloody oh
my god
holy [ __ ] on a stick oh nice
Oh oh great you know what I was
literally just about to say I hope I
gets warmed up by a waters going on here
is that piggy no don't tell me that's
piggy piggy oh all right all right
let's look Oh God we're so dead breasts
we've been pretty dead in our days but I
think this is the most dentists we've
ever been also this is a trap isn't it
let's not walk into it got it nailed it
all right then let's pull you down I
don't know what I just did but I did it
another one of those there what do they
do
oh [ __ ]
it's not a lot of enemies I'm completely
okay with this cuz I'll shoot them with
this electric flying harpoon everyone
has one of those in their backyard
trust me I can lit this on fire
oh cool I should probably not do that
though unless they're enemies that's oh
what what was that Oh something came out
of that and all right then oh god what
is that i totes heard something what is
that answer me
I will Electrify you all right
not today I suppose she says can this
game be a little bit more gory please oh
my god oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
attract
I can do that that's easy
come on oh good
alright friends it's been great what if
I shoot the electricity oh god oh god oh
god I'm dead oh god I'm dead I'm dead
alright I'm dying oh god you're so nice
oh Jesus Christ besides hi there you're
look great today
you'd look even better ah okay alright
you know at plan B Plan B plan B plan B
alright now that's great that's great
that's great I'm dead oh hey can you
move thank you I'm just gonna go over
here I'm going over here now jab bloody
soft on my advice all right that didn't
really go that well did it better hey
what are you gonna do seriously like
seriously
I'm gonna have to kill all
back off smile of Saturn oh Jesus
all right they're not too hard again I
think oh god the fatty okay [ __ ] I must
be really into some weird heavy metal or
some [ __ ]
Oh God all right now I just aim well aim
well fit that's really good that's
really good that's really good
come on one more come on come on hollow
that nice dad I hear someone I swear to
God - I hear someone you little badge no
bad batch oh oh oh she's still alive she
was still alive
dad lullaby all right
let's set it on fire because I don't
this girl is on fire abaca wonderful I
don't have any ammo whatsoever left good
job nice seriously wrong with this place
oh you don't you don't say really where
did you get that idea
Wow all right we have some shotgun ammo
let's let's go with a shouting shouting
this game is one big rap song mate I
mean the walls are leaking blood I think
that's a good good way to say that it
looks there's something seriously wrong
probably the pipes hello that's locked
hey what are you gonna do I like this
place it seems cozy I bet I'll meet your
friend here hello any friends all right
mo it's my friends oh that [ __ ] is
gonna come after me isn't she
nope [ __ ]
no oh oh you don't say mate oh god oh
god what in the walk alright alright
right I better get it better get out
it's been great it's been so good so far
love this place dolly feet done oh my
god are you crazy
all righty Tim let me heat am that me
I'm Swedish we don't taste very good
we're not amazing to Americans they're
fat and bacony run why did you write it
Wyatt serious are you serious right now
all right
okay I don't see anything okay all right
that will do that in that and then what
are you doing go down thank you
so good together with you don't tell me
chicken leather don't tell me she knows
how to ladder she has way too many arms
to know how to ladder Oh God don't punch
sit where they're lying
I don't know I don't think that the
weather line I don't know okay let's go
what is it women all right just come
what is it with you
who says [ __ ] like that are you alright
that's been great it's been so good I am
going back to my homeland and never I'm
gonna turn you make you into a little
fire did you like that [ __ ] Oh God Oh
My Jesus
oh my oh my oh my I am out of oh my what
the actual [ __ ] man come on don't no no
I don't want to go to school today mom
I'm sorry
No
what do you want from me do I look like
some kind of all right let's go
Oh God make it make it make it please oh
that's not too shabby damn it that was
close
that's all you got to say about that
that was close
damn it damn that's what I was going to
say you're taking a frickin break to
breathe oh my god are you kidding me oh
my god all right you know what you know
what I'm just gonna jog down these
stairs now and pretend that never
happened
what no no I can't I
I can't I can't it's the new Steve Jobs
all right then all right now I like sirs
- I'm glad we shared this little thing
together because stairs are really my
favorite thing in the whole world
you thought I was going to go down the
stairs it's like when you meet someone
you don't want to meet in the hallway oh
god they're right
what the [ __ ] oh come on there's babies
all right breasts that's the first part
of this demo or whatever it's super
awesome so far go ahead and leave it
like if you enjoyed this and you're
looking forward to more and I'll see you
in them in the next one brofist